- She's obviously a tense moment.
There's a lot of talk about
the counter offensive.
Is there anything you
can tell us about that?
(speaking in foreign language)
It's the eve of the counter offensive
that the world has been waiting for.
At one of the most consequential
moments since the war
in Ukraine began.
We traveled to the southern
port city of Odessa
to talk to the man at
the center of it all,
President Volodymyr Zelensky.
He was about to meet European leaders
to press for membership of
the European Union and NATO.
The big question,
how to cement Ukraine's
long-term security.
The big problem, I guess for you
and for the world is Putin
and the people around him still think
that they should be here.
So what does that mean for Ukraine
and what does it mean for the, you know,
the Western Alliance.
(speaking in foreign language)
(speaking in foreign language continues)
So obviously, you talking all the time
to your allies and you know,
there is going to be an
election in the US next year.
Does that worry you
because there could be a change
should Donald Trump win again?
Does that create a pressure on Ukraine
to sort of get the war finished?
(speaking in foreign language)
(speaking in foreign language continues)
President Zelensky told me he
doesn't have enough firepower
to defend his entire country.
While I was in Keith,
the night was punctuated
by loud explosions of missiles and drones.
Zelensky believes this is
Putin showing him that he needs
to make a choice protect
his cities or his troops
on the front line.
He says he can't do both
with the amount of weapons he has.
(speaking in foreign language)
(speaking in foreign language continues)
NATO will hold its next
summit in Vilnius, Lithuania
in July.
Pressure is grown to give
Ukraine security guarantees
and a path to membership.
Zelensky says he needs an explicit sign
that this will happen.
Are you optimistic that NATO
will admit you as a member?
(speaking in foreign language)
(speaking in foreign language continues)
Do you think you'll get that statement?
(speaking in foreign language)
What do you want from China?
You know, they are friendly with Russia.
What do you want or expect from China?
(speaking in foreign language)
(speaking in foreign language continues)
Before I sat down for this interview,
I followed Zelensky to a hospital
to visit wounded soldiers.
He spoke to a soldier
who had lost both hands
and comforted the young man's partner.
I saw firsthand how Zelensky
is facing the pain, suffering
and sadness that has come with this war.
So this was the first time
I'd seen the war up close
and it hit me like a,
I was very emotional.
You have to go in and
speak to the soldiers,
speak to the mother that
was standing outside.
I mean, how do you keep your morale up?
(speaking in foreign language)
You obviously never stop
working and even someone
who's at war has to find time to relax.
How do you switch off?
How do you ever relax?
(speaking in foreign language)
What do you read?
I don't suppose you
get much time for them.
(speaking in foreign language)
(both laughing)
- Very smart.
- Yes!
- I think so.
No-
- Check the kids' homework.
Aren't you?
(both laughing)
- No English.
- Oh, check their English.
- English with my son.
- Good, good.
And Harry's, his English, is it coming on?
- I think his English is better.
- Oh.
(both laughing)
You can practice with him!
Yeah.
That's wonderful.
- No, my daughter,
she knows English very well.
- Yes.
- She's better teacher for my son than me.
But sometimes when I see my son,
I want just to have some time
with him.
- Yes.
- And when even it
doesn't matter what to do.
- Yeah.
- I mean that-
- Just time.
- Yeah, exactly.
And time is the one thing
you don't have very much of,
right.
(speaking in foreign language)